STEVE MOULD: I'm talking about
an insect called a cicada.
They're in the news at the
moment in America.
They are a small
flying insect.
And the reason they're in the
news at the moment is because
they spend a huge amount of
their lives underground.
And very occasionally, they come
out in a big swarm for
the three F's-- feeding,
fighting, and mating.
And in America, this particular
cicada, it's called
a periodical cicada.
And this one comes out
every 17 years.
The reason I want to talk
about it is because it
illustrates an interesting way
that nature does maths,
because if you want to do maths,
if you want to solve a
problem in mathematics, what you
do is you start with all
the facts that you
already know.
You combine those facts together
using mathematical
logic to create some new fact
that you didn't know before.
So that's how you would prove
something in mathematics, how
you would solve a problem.
This is not what
they look like.
But let's have a go.
OK, so there's kind of--
imagine you've got
a lovely wing.
There you go.
It's mostly wing.
Big buggly red eyes.
Maybe there's an antenna kind of
going on, legs coming out,
something like that.
BRADY HARAN: That's real?
Are you serious?
STEVE MOULD: Yeah.
I mean, look, it's as close
as we're going to get.
I know it looks like kind of
a weird cow or something.
This illustrates the way
that nature does maths.
It's basically, instead of
having this logical,
methodical process, you just
sort of have a guess.
And you see if your
answer's correct.
You test it.
And if it's not correct, then
you try a new answer and see
if that gets you any closer, and
you keep trying and trying
and trying.
So it's a process of
trial and error.
And this is genuinely a way that
you can solve problems in
mathematics.
I think that the best example
of trial and error that the
world has ever seen
is evolution,
sort of natural selection.
So how has this happened
with the cicada?
Well, the first thing to know
about the cicada is that it
has a really interesting method
of protecting itself
against predators.
And that is something called
predator satiation, which is
basically where you make
yourself so numerous that your
predator is literally full.
It's too full, can't
eat anymore.
And that's how you survive.
But you sort of think, well,
how can that work?
Surely if you satiate your
predator, then your predator
is just going to come back
stronger in the next
generation and eat
even more of you.
That can only work for the
predator if the predator can
make its life cycle the
same as yours, so it's
in step with you.
So it's eating when you're
out and about doing
your thing as well.
And so the next thing the cicada
does is to make its
life cycle really,
really long, too
long for the predator.
For some reason, predators can't
have this really long
life cycle.
So that's why the cicada has
this really long life cycle.
It's to kind of get out of
step with the predator.
So let's look at that
on the number line.
1, 2, 3, 4--
15, 16, 17.
So let's write those out.
So 0, 1, 2, 3, 4--
15, 16, 17.
So this particular cicada that's
in the news comes out
every 17 years.
There's another one that comes
out every 13 years.
Is that important?
Could it be some other thing?
So for example, what if
the cicada chose a
12-year life cycle?
The predator, that's too
long for the predator.
It can't wait 12 years.
But the predator still
has a trick.
So maybe the predator has a
6-year life cycle instead.
So the predator comes
out after 6 years.
There's a predator comes
out there, and
there are no cicadas.
But the next generation of the
predator, that's at 12 years.
And suddenly, there are loads
of cicadas there.
And so every other generation
of the predator is able to
feed on cicadas.
And that gives them advantage,
and they will grow, and they
will flourish.
Or if 6 years is too long,
how about a 4-year cycle?
So we go 4 years, no cicadas.
8 years, no cicadas.
12 years, cicadas.
If 4 is too long, you could even
have a 3-year life cycle.
So the first 3 years,
no cicadas.
The second 3 years,
The third 3 years, no cicadas.
The fourth lot of 3 years,
that's 12 years, cicadas.
Even 2 years, that will
work as well.
So if you're a cicada and you
choose a 12-year life cycle,
that's a terrible decision,
because 12 has all these
things that you can
divide it into.
So 12 is divisible by 6,
divisible by 4, divisible by
3, and divisible by 2.
So if you're a cicada, you need
to choose a life cycle
which is not divisible
by anything.
So Brady, what's a
number that's not
divisible by anything?
BRADY HARAN: I'm no expert.
But I would reckon you're
heading here
towards prime numbers?
STEVE MOULD: Prime numbers.
Exactly.
So that is why the cicada has
chosen a 13-year life cycle
and a 17-year life cycle.
It's the solution to a
mathematical problem.
And it's the discovery of prime
numbers by natural selection.
Absolutely amazing.
Yeah.
So a cicada lives
for 17 years.
But 16 of those years are spent
underground in a sort of
larval state.
And then they come out in a big
swarm in the 17th year.
BRADY HARAN: 13 and 17 years
seems like a long time.
There are a lot of prime numbers
lower than that.
STEVE MOULD: Well,
yes, there are.
But I suppose the issue with
smaller numbers is that just
maybe the predator could
stretch to having a
life cycle that long.
And so they can get
into step with it.
The great thing is, by the way,
if you've got, say, a
13-year life cycle and your
predator has a 4-year life
cycle, how often will the
predator and the prey meet?
Well, it's 4 times 13,
or 4 times 17.
So you have to multiply the two
numbers together, and it
becomes this enormous thing.
And that's the genius.
If there was some common factor
to these two, then you
wouldn't have to multiply
them together to find
out when they meet.
It would be a much
smaller number.
The predator is a wasp.
It's called the cicada-killing
wasp.
I don't know where they got
that name from, but
those guys are crazy.
Yeah, the wasp is great.
It basically kills the
cicada with a sting.
And then it plants an egg inside
the cicada's dead body,
which then feeds on it from the
inside and then releases a
wasp at the end of this.
Great way to go.
But yeah, I love the idea of
satiating your predator.
You really don't want to be in
the vanguard of the cicada
group when that's your policy.
You have to go really far down
this approximation route
before you get close to the
golden ratio, much more so
than pi or whatever.
So the golden ratio is the
most irrational number.